Six
types of
unhealthy father sons relationships
In romantic comedy
drama film garden state main character Andrew
returns to his hometown to attend his mother's funeral
Andrew's father, a psychiatrist
blamed Andrew for his mother's death
and put him on medications to try and control his emotions
Believing it was Andrew's anger
that triggered his mother's accident
People often say sons grow up to be as great as their fathers
But what happen to those of us who
grew up without a dad or had a tough
upbringing from them? We want to inform the public
just how important it is to understand
how toxic family dynamics can affect
the individuals state of being
Here's six types of unhealthy father son relationships
One. The absent father.
A special shout out goes to coffee drop who mentioned
the absent father in our recent video
six types of unhealthy father daughter relationships
If you haven't already, please check it out after this
The absent father was never around
when you needed him
CEO and co-founder
of psych2go Tai Khuong
can strongly relate to this
His father left Tai and his family when he was little
Tai's father is a businessman
who is constantly sucked into his work
There's nothing wrong with being passionate about your career
But his father has an unhealthy obsession with making money
As a result
he lost sight on finding a purpose from his work
causing him to spiral down in dark empty holes
Tai was never emotionally and physically nurtured by his father
This abandoned man can be detrimental to the son's emotion and physical development over time. Tai learnt what not
to become from his absent father and his passionate
about growing psych2go into a bigger platform
hoping to raise mental health awareness and help others who have been through similar struggles as him
Two. The addict father.
The addict father is someone who struggles with some sort of addiction
whether its
alcoholism, gambling, drug abuse or pornography
unfortunately, Tai also relates to this one. Due to his father's unhappiness
Due to his father's unhappiness and competitive nature of being money hungry
he struggles with alcoholism
If you haven't already, please check out our video later
Seven ways alcoholic parents affect their children
Sons with an addict father
have a fear of being vulnerable
because of their emotional instability their fathers instilled within their lives
They are often scared to open up to others
afraid of being let down, hurt and rejected
This can strongly affect their ability to form
close intimate friendships and
relationships with romantic partners
Three. The harsh father
This type of father is overly strict and tough on his son
with frequent angry outbursts
The family often does not feel safe
making mistakes and showing their
flaws around them
The harsh father could be
and expects everyone in the household to follow his rules
and regulations. Sons who
grow up with this type of father usually feel like
their upbringing was more constricting
than life giving
Often the father guilt trips the son
blaming him for not being good enough
rather than teaching him on how to get better in something
This type of father
is usually moody
unpredictable and feared by his son
Four. The performing father
The performing father is someone who often
immerses himself in work or hobbies
He doesn't
enjoys sitting down with his kids
and spending quality time with them. Instead
he always feels like he has to keep busy
and has a hard time relaxing. The performing father
is obsessed
with performing well and always
pushes himself to get better. Goal-oriented
he focused on result, success and achievements
In the workplace, he usually has a great reputation
and many of his co-workers find him
responsible, reliable and level-headed
At home, however, sons of
the performing father feel neglected
and rarely ever get their own needs met. As a result
they missed out learning important life skills
and they struggled with low self-esteem issues
Feeling like they can't meet the high standards of their
own father.
Five. The passive father
Similar to
the
performing father
the passive father also has a great work ethic in the workplace
But instead of being busy at home too. The passive
father leads a very uneventful
life after he clocks out from work
Emotionally unavailable, he leaves
all the work
and chores up to the mum
including picking up the kids from school
all and spending quality time with them
This father although he is still physically present in the family
His often emotionally distant
and doesn't interact much with his son. I grow up
with a passive father and even to this day
it's hard for me to bond with him
Six. The abusive father
The abusive father forms intense emotional and physical wounds household
He often mistreats his son
through physical, verbal, emotional
and or sexual abuse
This can take a massive toll on the sons's emotional and
physical development and can deeply hurt the self esteem
Often, sons of abusive father
can grow up either being abusive themselves
or victims
of abusive romantic relationships
Which type of unhealthy father son
relationship do you resonate with
We know how hard it is to talk about toxic
family dynamics and want to be
a safe non-judgmental place for you
Please share your story with us down below
We also want to remind you that you are worth
so much more than the mistreatment
you have experienced in your childhood. Toxic patterns
are hard to break out of. But with an heart
of awareness and courage
they can be conquered
Please don't forget to also
subscribe for more content
from psych2go and check out our patron
Thanks for watching